grab your cave and gear and don't get
frightened because we have the most
thrilling film about cave since Journey
to the Center of the Earth
the descent is one of my all-time
favorite horror films so in this video
we're gonna take a deep dive into its
ending and some of the things you might
have missed along the way I'll also be
going over the differences between the
UK and US theatrical versions because
one ending in my opinion is way better
than the other at its surface the
descent is a film about a group of women
who struggled to escape a cave system
infested with ravenous creatures known
as crawlers but what this film is really
about is one woman's struggle to
overcome the pain of losing her daughter
in the beginning of the film our
protagonist sara is out whitewater
rafting with two of her friends Juno and
Beth while her husband and daughter
watch from the side this is a great
setup since it establishes everyone's
relationship to one another while
simultaneously showing us that they're
thrill-seekers the rafting also
juxtaposes the quaint car ride in the
next scene where we as the viewer have
let our guard down only for a huge jump
scare to occur which sets the story in
motion the death of Sarah's husband and
daughter but even before this event the
writer and director are setting up key
hints that will pay off later in the
film mainly how Sarah's husband Peter
was having an affair with Juno for
example when the ladies get off the raft
Juno immediately goes to Peter who helps
her take off her helmet this interaction
is clocked by Beth who gives us somewhat
worrying look hinting that she too
either knows about the affair or at
least suspects something in the car
moments before the crash Sarah says to
Peter you can't you seem a bit distant
clearly something is on Peters mind and
this something is his infidelity it's
also in this scene that Sarah has a
throw off line telling her daughter
Jessica that when they get home they can
plan her birthday party it's this
birthday cake and image of her daughter
which becomes a recurring motif that
haunts Sarah throughout the story waking
up in the hospital the only survivor of
the crash
Sarah experiences her first
hallucination with the lights in the
hospital turning off behind her as she's
thrust back into reality by her friends
learning of the death of her husband and
daughter
now this scene is also interesting
because Juno here instead of rushing to
console her friend like Beth does she
simply leaves not just the hospital but
the entire country without even saying
goodbye to Sara likely feeling guilty
over her affair with Paul in his death
as will later find out Juno and Paul's
affair wasn't just a one-time fling they
loved each other as evidenced by the
necklace Paul gave her which we'll get
to in a bit the crash also had another
effect on Sara drug addiction and it's
quite easy to miss the drugs in question
seem to help Sara with PTSD from the
crash and to help her cope with the loss
of her child we only see her take these
pills once after she experiences a
nightmare about the crash a nightmare
which is accompanied by giggles from her
daughter as we flash forward one year to
the appellations the adventuresome girls
gather to take on a cave and one of the
girls Holly says this to Sara always
searching for the next big hi sorry Sara
immediately thinks Holly's hi is
referring to her drugs when in fact it's
just the high of adrenaline you
experienced when doing extreme sports
Juno also has a picture taken by Paul
with the inscription love each day this
saying is later found engraved on Juno's
necklace which was a present from Paul
and it's how Sara later finds out Juno
was fooling around with her husband
there's also another subtle hint that
the girls know about the affair
when Juno comes in and says this line to
Sam and Holly Sam's response here is
really weird
what once is she referring to this is
yet another subtle clue that proves the
other girls knew about Juno's affair
the girls eventually make their way to
what they believe is an easy cave system
called Boreham caverns but little do
they know Juno has done away with a
guidebook and taken them to an uncharted
system
she has withheld this information and
lied to them just like what she did with
Sara and her affair with Paul as they
make their way to the cave Rebecca
Lissa's series of side effects cavers
might experience while caving
dehydration disorientation the inclusion
of paranoia and hallucinations here are
really important because Sarah will be
increasingly plagued by visions of her
daughter as this story and her paranoia
progress there's even some foreshadowing
of the carnage to come with weird blood
marks near the caves entrance and the
mutilated body of a dead deer deers are
known as symbols of trust and to see one
mutilated here is a reference to the
broken trust between Juno and Sarah
there are also symbols of new adventure
hence the start of their expedition but
their adventure takes a turn when the
cave collapses leaving them trapped
below with creatures known as the
crawlers not much is known about them
but they have evolved perfectly to live
in the dark completely blind using sound
to communicate with one another their
bodies have adapted to be able to climb
the caves jagged walls and easily
traverse its many cramped spaces but
perhaps the most shocking moment of the
movie happens when Juno accidentally
kills Beth mistaking her from one of the
crawlers instead of staying there with
her Juno leaves just like she left after
the death of Paul but before Juno leaves
Beth is able to rip off her necklace
which will later be discovered by Sarah
confirming Juno's affair with her
husband it's this revelation combined
with the fact Juno left Beth to die that
compels Sarah to stab Juno with her
pickaxe in the leg leaving her to defend
herself against the approaching crawlers
with Sarah being the only survivor left
she makes her way to the caves second
entrance a second entrance which was
discovered by the girls through ancient
Native American cave paintings buried
deep within the cave that combined with
old markers left by a previous caving
expedition from the early 1900's who
never made it out
Sarah is able to find her way but here's
where things get really interesting
right before Sarah makes her way out she
falls down a small pit and is knocked
unconscious for a few seconds and it's
at this time the lighting switches from
her torch to daylight now this can be
interpreted in two ways that the
daylight just happens to shine in that
exact moment or that this is her
transitioning into a hallucination and I
think it's a lot
of the two we know from earlier that
sarah only experiences these
hallucinations when she's either
sleeping or knocked unconscious earlier
in the film when Sarah nearly makes it
out of the cave collapse
she's briefly incapacitated and
experiences a vision of her daughter
with the birthday cake these moments
where her head gets bonked around seems
to trigger these visions the second
reason I believe it's hallucination has
to do with the UK version of the ending
so here's where the US theatrical and UK
endings slightly differ in both versions
Sarah makes her way out of the cave into
the car and stops by the side of the
road after letting out a bit of her
lunch she composes herself only to find
the ghost of Juno beside her that's
where the US version ends but if you
watched the UK version this story
continues Sarah wakes up back in the
cave in the same position right when she
was knocked unconscious the whole escape
from the cave was all in her mind just
like her daughter who is now in front of
her with the birthday cake but as the
camera pushes back we see there is no
daughter no birthday cake it was all in
her imagination as the sounds of the
crawlers intensify around her this
ending was deemed too dark for American
audiences and thus was cut from the
theatrical release I prefer the UK
ending because it wraps up Sarah's
character and pays off the visions of
her daughter which were built up
throughout the film
but what ending do you guys prefer also
this is my first attempt at going back
and doing older movies so I want to hear
your thoughts should I do more like this
and if so what should I do next make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and go ahead
and follow me on Twitter for the latest
updates at the Bing story YT until next
time remember daddy loves you very much